hi I'm Matt here's the deal a few months
ago several months ago actually I was
supposed to make a video about
Valentine's Day we cast Kelsey Darragh
and her boyfriend Jared hi I'm Kelsey
and I'm Jared how you feel about
Valentine's Day
that's okay love love school we
interviewed them and we found out what
their ideal date was I was thinking it
could be fun to experience a day at like
a luxury hotel in Los Angeles I was
thinking about a tandem bike ride in
Venice Valentine's Day came and went
spring turned to summer and I just
missed the deadline but what I did learn
in their intro interviews which was most
interesting to me is that their ideal
date was so different from each other's
I thought a much more interesting video
would be to see which one of their dates
was better Kelsey's ideal date was in
that at a luxury hotel may be a day at
the W which has a really good pool it's
very contemporary very modern and has an
awesome restaurant downstairs and so
it's more of like a staycation which I
think could be really fun and Jared's
was like a tandem bike on the boardwalk
cuz just goofy she could have a glass of
it and plus like a pedal
I wonder how their relationship works
out if that's so wildly different so I
present you now what is better going on
a nice staycation in a luxury hotel or
glamping glamping I believe is
glamorized camping for those not in the
know so let's do it
[Music]
we have arrived all right shake it out
just like the hotel commander I don't
know don't worry about what about happen
it was giraffe again yeah we have a full
oh my god
we're like in a full suite we got a
patio - why look they gave this little
what are these cold records cuz you're a
DJ that's a personalized touch baby
should we take a look around yes we
carry our party cups okay first of all
this is a nice living room I've ever
seen in my life this is insane
I want to live here oh my god I've got a
backhoe and then we've got a kitchen bar
over here I'm go see outside yep we've
got a full-on like dinner I don't even
know why someone would rent this room
why would anyone even rent that in this
big room
I mean we're tall but we're not that
tall let's go jump on that bed oh now
that we've seen the room I'm gonna need
you to chill here cuz I gotta go do some
stuff that you can't be a part of Jay
you go take her I'll do whatever you do
I'll see you later bye so I told Jared
that they had a pool here and my plan
worked he left to go hang out by the
pool which is great for me because now I
have a couple minutes to
with the W insider which is basically
like a free concierge service where
she's gonna help me plan a bunch of
activities we have like nothing to do
today vacation I'm with my girl here we
like to create inside experiences for
all of our guests whether you're into
wine massages nice dinners rooftops we
really want to cater and hone in on the
Hollywood experience can you get a
helicopter here we can not do that okay
anything that's illegal like what you
said about the massage yeah cuz he's
broken in all sorts of places so I feel
like maybe it does that yeah and they
can do that in the room yeah I was like
let's make it more romantic let's set it
up in your room really set the scene in
the romance no yeah oh my god is this a
romantic I like it okay so how about we
do massages head and dinner cuz I mean
like girls well done and done Kelsie
perfect thank you so much relocated yeah
let's set it up okay are you ready for
your first surprise yeah
a staycation I ever wanted staycation
Matt does any massages it's a weird
crazy LA kind well weird I like crazy
massages all right Jared it's getting a
very cool sports massage
yeah and part of the cool massage is
that they also like stretch you for 30
minutes it's time to relax
lord knows a we meet it enjoying this
that's the word thinking what's robbing
you
I gotta get more sports massages as what
I think I've learned from this I didn't
even know there were muscles where you
are I don't know why we're Howard even
walking right now after the thing about
it but now I need a wheelbarrow I made a
reservation for my favorite restaurant
they have my favorite out of it oh this
is your place so we're gonna go with
pappardelle I'm so devastated because
after all of this they are out of season
with the helmet but they do say they
have a pretty insane sea bass and some
scallops we got for our sauce proud that
steak
no can't look
I wrote today the one thing about
luxurious vacations is bet I am
exhausted by everything my breathing is
so rich in family that I'm like a tired
I'm about to pass out at 7 o'clock
checkout is in that okay you ready
[Music]
oh my god I can't get over this Batman
it's an infinity bath we just found out
too well we did our in-room bathtub how
did you like your staycation yeah you
killed it
now do you understand what a staycation
is I get it what's your favorite part
massages bottles were crazy good all
right you thinking about me I mean I'm
supposed to say yes but probably not
okay here we are on the road go into a
place I have no idea what we're doing or
what we're seeing or anything we're just
driving north I tried to question you
about packing last night
you said a Sun Hat oh something to
minimize the amount of Sun yeah I
figured that's a purpose of a literal
hat I feel like this is gonna be fun for
me two years ago if you told me to like
get in the car and we were just gonna
drive for an overnight date I would tell
you to get the [ __ ] out of my house you
serial partner like I would never
two years ago do something like that
why we middle of the desert on the side
of the road at a gas station because
we're going ATV and baby what I
predicted Jared didn't tell me what
we're doing me and you telling the
proper outlets to air impact so this is
what we're stuck with let's do this
[Music]
[Applause]
oh damn
yeah you have a good time huge shout out
to a fun time a TV and Canty of
California for that matter that was just
long yeah thank you but I'm hungry
well maybe it's time to go to the hotel
hotel yeah baby oh my god we are in the
debt wild y'all look that's a snake
snake whoa
you like it yeah it's cool
which one's ours everything the light
touches is yours look at friggin that
tada
Wow a solar panel so it's good for the
environment
boom we are in the middle of no go
oh my God look at this shower it's like
it's a Russia hour it's a room shower
that we don't have to the gets so much
water out into the in nature hatred
naked the whole time we're here ooh
Wow if you live in another country yeah
this is uh I don't even know man let's
take two now supposedly we can sleep
with the doors open doors over never saw
a freaking snake are you thanks for our
friends you know not bad things I'm not
getting eaten by snake tell you that
much
and here you see a bed tonight I'm gonna
cook you dinner with the best view in
California you don't know how to cook I
am gonna be cutting yeah okay I might
hear we got a fire pit we have
marshmallows you pick out forget the
marshmallows oh sweet excited yeah let's
get all our stuff and get to relax it I
can't wait to do nothing whoo
[Music]
it's not time we got the big
marshmallows known to mankind by a
grenade that's where I had the most
beautiful group of my life earlier well
we did it whoo what I think healthy
we're in our little pod this is great we
made a fire would be dinner and then we
took a shower that had three showerhead
and then now we're away at our pot
watching National Geographic cuz we feel
very connected to nature but not like
that to make certain nature where I'm
trying like you know be bitten by things
but definitely super close this is funny
do you think it's important to do date
night damn right you do date nights are
essential or else everything just kind
of wishes together yeah you gotta have
these like moments remember this it's a
big thing yeah Wow yeah I hate to admit
a loss but I know when I'm wrong and
this was epic I think this wins right
this is a big w Oh
but the W this is a bigger than I think
Oh you so much I love it yeah they like
[Music]